we could use this against a ball that's
brilliant I'm totally on board except
mental activity dampener Ramon the names
no good which is why-- drumroll please
I've decided to rename this the cerebral
inhibitor this is where we came up with
the cerebral inhibitor to use against a
bow oh hey everybody's charlie this is
gonna be my flash episode 14 video we
got a bunch of explainers especially for
last season thats avatar cerebral
inhibitor teaser turns out he was
telling us what was going on without
telling us the whole story which sounds
like a very savage car thing to do like
I'm just gonna conveniently leave out
the part where they get their asses
handed to them so if you're finding me
for the first time there is a new round
of that flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so top 10
WTF comic book Easter eggs starting with
number 10 Barry has to leave central
city police department not because
anybody hates him but just because of
this confluence of public perception the
new mayor is trying to crack down so I
think it's mostly a plot device to get
to that private detective business stuff
at the end of the episode the way
elongated man explained it made it sound
like it was more of a temporary solution
so I don't know that he would ever
completely leave central city police
department but I think they want to try
this out and if it works well from a
story perspective an elongated man
sticks around next season then they'll
just continue on as private detectives
but we'll always have Central City
Police Department connections because
you have Cecile and Joe that are there
all the time you have captain's sing so
this is actually kind of a good thing
because if he were still there he'd
actually have to do regular casework
while he's trying to take down the
thinker so now is just 100% on the
thinker but they do a lot of explaining
in this episode explaining how
technology works like with Cecile and
Harrison wells about the cerebral
inhibitor but also about the medes that
are left as well is what's happening to
the thinker's body so number 9 thinkers
body is degenerating at an exponentially
increasing rate the more meta powers
that she absorbs which is why they were
probably a couple lines of dialogue that
made you prick your ears up when Caitlyn
was talking about how fast Barry in
elongated man shrugged off those sonic
abilities when the Fiddler's blast
them like oh it's a really good thing
that you have your powers because you're
healing super fast while the thinker's
body is literally eating itself alive so
I think there's just a teaser for her
eventually needing a body that can
regenerate really fast which is both
elongated man and beery but obviously we
have the big running theory that
elongated man's body is going to be used
to recreate the original version of the
thinker because Neil salyanz' is a
fantastic actor in Kevin Smith was
posting pictures of him on set with his
crazy long beard so maybe they were just
using his voice but he was on set for
something it sounds like we'll
eventually see another version of him
like when we saw elongated man mimic his
body and I love the way that they
followed up on that plot line to captain
Singh is like oh yeah he's been coming
in cooperating with us but nobody
believes that it's really him because
central city is so lousy with metahumans
it's so much crazy stuff has happened
also really happy that they addressed
that - you have a city where you have
all this craziness happening you think
the people would wise up to it
eventually like oh you know what that
person he might be psychic maybe I'm
being mind-controlled to do all these
terrible things or maybe that bank
robber has some special powers and
that's how they got all that money but
number 8 the flash does their version of
the Fiddler's they explain it's a she
not a he and they like even use that
country music song I think they wanted
to use a popular song that people
recognized but they sort of wink at the
comic book origin of the character and
eventually give her the fiddle but it's
really the thinker that gives her that
Fiddler's name and I'm totally fine with
them changing the character the version
from the comics was an old man he
fiddled people mostly mind control the
way they explained her power pretty much
like black siren Black Canary just sonic
blast maybe she could do something
cooler with it later on because the
thinker is pretty sophisticated with the
way she uses all those abilities in
conjunction with each other love that
they name the bar the broken saddle
because they both get busted asses by
the end of their first encounter with
her in Cisco drops that transformers
reference to bad Soundwave is already
taken by a transformer
number Seven's the seal in harrison
wells come up with the plan to make the
cerebral inhibitor although they don't
know that's what it is at the beginning
and she walks in with that device that
looks like it's right out of Back to the
Future on her head the sort of back up
to cecile storyline like they tried to
weave in a couple different things so
one it was important because of the
cerebral inhibitor but the other part
was because of the Jessie quick stuff
and then they also use her to explain a
lot of stuff like explain to me how does
this cerebral inhibitor work oh well it
blocks incoming thoughts what if you
could reverse the polarity so because
Joe was not in the episode Cecile got to
be the explainer character like there's
always one character on the flash it's
like doesn't understand what the science
people are talking about please explain
it to me like I'm stupid so if you ever
wonder why they always do stuff like
that that's mostly the network asking
the writers to explain really complex
concepts for audience members that
either don't read the comics or aren't
following along but the funny thing
behind the scenes is that the actors
that place the seal posted a picture of
this and people were like holy is
the cerebral inhibitor how is it going
to work it turns out number six they can
use it specifically to stop DeVoe from
jumping into different bodies although
it didn't go exactly the way they had
planned it but the whole idea is is that
they'll probably try to create some more
technology like Cisco said it worked the
way it was supposed to work it's just
that they didn't account for all the
thinkers different abilities working in
conjunction like if he hadn't had
Kilgore's powers it would have totally
worked so I'll explain why that is in
just a second it's not quite as
complicated as you think they're just
trying to like point Barry in a specific
direction with the way he fights the
thinker this season number 5 Barry
pushing the Fiddler's too hard in
training causing her to bail which sort
of leads to her eventually getting her
powers taken if you're wondering why
they wrote Barry this way like it felt
relatively believable that he would
really want to save her and just try to
push her a little too hard the real
reason was because of that iris
conversation that he had after she left
where she was like maybe there's another
way to fight Deveaux and what I think
they were using that scene for was two
T's that they're gonna use Marley's the
thinker's wife to fight the thinker like
the alternate way instead of trying to
run up and punch the thinker in the face
you used to think
wife because they had that really big
bite during the episode the thinker had
to straight-up roofie her in order to
get her to go along with the plan
so the actress in real life also
corroborated that like she's like
definitely not down with what the
thinker is doing like he's going full
comic book villain eventually he'll push
her too far and that'll be team Flash's
opportunity to help get her on their
side like help us rescue your husband
like they always want to humanize all
the villains on this TV show give you
their perspective the thinker's wife
only cares about her husband in right
now the person that we're looking at is
not her husband he's like this crazy
comic-book amalgam of seven different
characters all jammed into one number
four course Savatage cerebral inhibitor
totally doesn't work the way they
expected to although you know like I
said Cisco mentioned it worked the way
it was supposed to it's just that the
thinker has too many abilities to
counter the effects but like we've been
talking about this season you think a
couple chest moves ahead of course the
thinker's body is degenerating faster
she'll need elongated man's body Barry's
body eventually what better way to speed
that up than to have her take the rest
of these bust metas so I think obviously
we're expecting the thinker to take the
abilities of these other three metas
that we haven't seen yet Barry and team
flash will try to save them they'll be
unsuccessful and ultimately Barry will
get taken himself and there'll be some
crazy twist in how they defeat the
thinker but it will only be after Barry
has also become one with the thinker
like a lot of people keep making that we
are the flash joke there's a moment
coming with an iris episode which i
think is specifically what they were
using that for think about it this way
the thinker takes Barry's mind and says
we are the flash because now the thinker
will have become the flash so I think
that's really what the we are the flash
is building towards even though this
iris moment where she becomes a
speedster is part of that to the big
number three though is that while they
get their asses handed to them they find
out about the pocket dimension that the
thinker has been using this whole time
I wondered how they were gonna explain
that special space I knew it would be a
little bit different from reality
because of the way it functions but it's
also sort of a tee up for the concept of
flash time like them moving at super
speed through a
lately alternate-dimension because
they're speedsters they have access to
the Speed Force
it sort of bends the laws of physics in
a way that you wouldn't normally think
about because of the way Dark Matter
works
number two Barry becomes a private
detective like I said the big thing with
this is just seeing how long it sticks I
think if people really like it then
Barry will continue to be a private
detective but a lot of that has to do
with whether or not elongated man sticks
around for season five so just open up a
tab in chrome we'll check back at the
end of the season and see if the
producers say anything about that but
number one of course the big one between
Harrison wells and Cecile she gives him
the idea to invite Jessie quick and
that's why she's around for the
crossover next week but it doesn't
explain why Jay Garrick is around and a
lot have you been asking about wally
west if you haven't been watching
legends he is now with rip hunter that's
why he's not around for the flash family
episode next week so everybody let me
know what was your favorite part of the
episode we're going to flash family
crazy town next week it's gonna be
awesome
and then episode 16 is run iris run and
then there's like really crazy stuff
happening in episode 17 18 and 19 if you
remember the way they've done it the
last couple of seasons that's really
when you do crazy mythology stuff but
there's another episode that's titled
pay it forward which is coming up I
don't know which one it is but I believe
that that will also be a big coffee shop
girl episode but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Nate plays please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there was a new round on
this video I'll name the winner when I
post my trailer video tomorrow morning
so click here to get a preview for the
actual Shazam costume the Zachary Levi
is gonna wear when he plays Billy Batson
and click here to learn all about the
Deadpool TV series that's coming up in
May thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight